>> PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
JAYLA CONTINUED TO STRAY
FROM HER RELIGIOUS UPBRINGING.
>> I'M A FORNICATOR.
I'M A SMOKER.
I'M A HORRIBLE EXAMPLE
OF WHAT A JEHOVAH'S WITNESS
IS SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE.
LET'S TAKE THE TOPS AWAY.
YEAH! WHOO!
>> AND LISA'S EXTROVERTED
PERSONALITY STARTED
TO RUB CORYN THE WRONG WAY.
>> I SAID I DON'T LIKE YOU.
HOW MUCH MORE--
>> IT'S JUST GONNA MAKE
YOU FEEL BAD.
>> AND DIANE'S SPARKLE DIMMED.
>> BEAUTIFUL GIRL, SHE'S
JUST NOT A MODEL.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
EIGHT GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
>> WE JUST GOT THROUGH
ELIMINATIONS...
(sniffles)
AND DIANE WAS ELIMINATED.
SHE WAS THE CLOSEST PERSON TO ME
IN THE HOUSE,
AND I FEEL REALLY VULNERABLE.
I DON'T WANT TO LET ANYONE IN.
I DON'T WANT TO BE HURT.
THE ONLY PERSON I HAVE IS
MYSELF,
AND I JUST PROBABLY WILL BE,
LIKE,
A QUIET GIRL FROM NOW ON.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE GONE,
AND IT'S ACTUALLY BETTER.
I'M NOT GONNA BE SATISFIED
UNLESS I'M NUMBER ONE,
AND I WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO GET THERE.
I WILL CLAW MY WAY TO THE TOP
IF I HAVE TO.
♪♪♪
>> YOU WANT BUBBLES?
>> YEAH.
>> I CANNOT STAND LISA.
SHE TOLD ME THAT IF I WANT
TO BE A SUPERMODEL AND DO
FASHION AND STUFF LIKE THAT,
I NEED TO STOP WORKING OUT,
BECAUSE MY BODY IS TOO TONED.
>> CORYN?
>> WHAT?
>> YOU NEED TO STOP WORKING OUT.
>> WHY WOULD I LISTEN TO
SOMEBODY
I'M COMPETING AGAINST?
SHE THINKS THAT SHE
KNOWS EVERYTHING.
I'M HOPING LISA GOES.
♪♪♪
>> LISA IS CONSTANTLY NEEDING
TO BE THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
EVERYBODY ELSE,
BUT I LOVE BUBBLES.
>> I LOVE 'EM, TOO.
>> BUBBLES.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING WEIRD
ABOUT LISA, AND I CAN'T REALLY
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS.
>> AH! (laughing)
>> LISA DRINKS.
SHE'S GOING THROUGH, LIKE,
BOTTLES OF WINE--
LIKE, WHOLE BOTTLES
IN LESS THAN 45 MINUTES.
IT'S SICK.
>> I ALMOST FEEL LIKE
THE BUBBLES ARE OWNING YOU,
AND YOU AREN'T OWNING
THE BUBBLES.
>> BUBBLES!
>> I THINK AT THIS POINT,
EVERYONE'S JUST PRETTY
MUCH TIRED OF LISA.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I
DON'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS.
>> MAYBE SHE'LL GET ELIMINATED
BECAUSE SHE'S ALL OVER
THE PLACE, AND WE'LL BE
OFF THE HOOK FOR ANOTHER WEEK.
>> HEY, GIRLS, IT'S JAY.
>> WE ARE TOLD TO COME
UPSTAIRS TO THIS TABLE
WHERE ALL THIS FOOD IS SET UP.
AND I'M THINKING,
"ARE WE GONNA, LIKE,
HAVE A COOKING COMPETITION?
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
HOUSEWIVES TODAY?"
>> I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME
I WORKED WITH MY FIRST,
LIKE, ICON. SO I HAD TO BRING
HER HERE.
MISS THING?
>> OOH!
>> NO WAY.
>> HI, GIRLS.
>> HI!
>> IT WAS IMAN.
AND IMAN'S, LIKE, SO COOL.
>> THIS IS IMAN'S BEAUTY BOOK,
AND EVEN MISS TYRA
IS IN THE BOOK.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF MODELING THAT I WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND IS SKIN CARE
IS KEY, KEY, KEY.
IT DON'T MATTER A THING
IF YOU AIN'T GOT THAT SKIN.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
ORGANIC PRODUCTS,
HOME PRODUCTS,
THAT YOU CAN MAKE--
VERY EASY TO MAKE YOURSELF
HAVE FLAWLESS SKIN.
WE'RE GONNA HAND OUT
THESE RECIPES.
YOU GUYS CAN USE
EVERYTHING RIGHT HERE.
ARE YOU READY TO START?
GO AHEAD.
♪♪♪
>> WHAT IS IN YOURS?
HONEY AND...
>> IT FEELS REALLY GROSS.
IT'S SLIMY AND GOOEY,
AND YOU GOT LITTLE CHUNKS
EVERYWHERE.
>> MOST CLIENTS WILL JUDGE YOU
OF HOW YOUR SKIN LOOKS.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY,
ALSO THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT RETOUCHING EXPENSES.
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO RETOUCH
YOUR WHOLE SKIN.
>> I WAS WONDERING WHAT,
SPECIFICALLY, THE AVOCADO DOES
TO YOUR SKIN.
>> YOU USE IT AS A
MOISTURIZING MASK.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT
YOUR PRODUCT DOES?
>> MINE'S AN EXFOLIANT.
THE OATMEAL SCRAPES
OFF DEAD SKIN.
>> BRE, YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO WEAR IT, NOT EAT IT.
SO YOU MUST BE WONDERING
WHY WE HAD YOU PUT FOOD
ALL OVER YOUR FACE TODAY.
WELL, YOU'RE ALL
GONNA BE CHALLENGED
ON BEING SPOKESMODELS
FOR THE HONEY BANANA
FIRMING MASK.
YOU'LL APPEAR ON A
MOCK TALK SHOW SEGMENT,
AND YOU MUST GET YOUR
KEY PRODUCT POINTS
ACROSS DURING THE INTERVIEW.
PASS THESE OUT.
THESE ARE TALKING POINTS
THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO USE.
YOUR CLIENT IS GONNA WANT
TO HEAR THOSE SOUND BITES
IN THAT INTERVIEW.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SAY EVERYTHING,
BUT YOU HAVE TO PICK
THE KEY ELEMENTS
THAT YOU THINK WILL SELL
TO THE CLIENT.
BYE.
>> BYE!
>> THANKS.
♪♪♪
>> I'M CHRIS SPENCER,
STAND-UP COMEDIAN
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
USED TO BE A SUPERMODEL
BEFORE THE FIRE.
AS MODELS,
SOMETIMES YOU'RE GONNA
BE ASKED TO BE SPOKESPERSONS
AS WELL AS ENDORSE
CERTAIN PRODUCTS.
NOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A 3-MINUTE INTERVIEW WITH ME.
THERE'LL BE ONE WINNER.
THE REST OF YOU,
BACK TO COMPTON.
>> THERE'S TEN LINES
THAT YOU HAVE TO MEMORIZE,
AND I HAVE THEM DOWN.
I DO.
AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING,
AND I'M LIKE THIS...
THIS TAKES THE BUTTERFLIES AWAY.
IT DOES, SERIOUSLY. TRY IT.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M NOT SCARED
TO GET IN FRONT
OF SOMEBODY AND TALK.
I'M FEELING REALLY GOOD
ABOUT THECHALLENGE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A PRODUCT
YOU WANT TO TELL ME ABOUT?
>> I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT ANTM
HONEY AND BANANA FACE CREAM.
IN THE BANANA,
THERE IS FOLIC ACID,
AND THERE'S VITAMIN C,
AND THEY'RE REALLY GOOD
AT CLEANING OUT YOUR PORES.
>> YOU PROBABLY SHOULD
ADD PAPAYA TO IT.
JAYLA WAS PUTTING ME TO SLEEP.
I WAS BORED TO DEATH.
>> IT'S BANANAS AND HONEY.
IT'S A FACIAL MASK.
>> SO YOU PROBABLY
CAN'T WEAR IT OUTSIDE
'CAUSE OF FLIES AND STUFF.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO
WEAR THIS OUTSIDE.
>> I MEAN, I HATE TO BE
HAVING A MASK ON...
(imitates buzzing)
DAMN IT, STAY OFF OF MY MASK!
>> THANKS.
>> CORYN, SHE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
SHE HAD NO IDEA.
>> I HAVE THIS PRODUCT...
>> OKAY.
>> AND IT'S AWESOME, BECAUSE--
>> (grunts)
>> DON'T INTERRUPT ME,
'CAUSE I'M TRYING
TO TELL YOU SOMETHING.
>> BUT THE TONGUE RING
HAS GOT ME EXCITED.
>> WOULD YOU LOOK AT
MY SKIN FIRST?
>> YOU KINKY.
>> GOT TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
THEM PRODUCT POINTS, BRE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE HEARD OF ANTM.
>> THAT'S A COLLEGE.
>> YOU KNOW, A LOT OF KIDS THERE
PROBABLY USE THIS NEW FACE MASK.
>> FOOTBALL TEAM WEARS
FACE MASKS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> LET ME SEE WHAT'S
ON YOUR HAND.
THESE ARE PRODUCT POINTS!
IS THAT CHEATING?
(buzzer)
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> IF YOU HAVE TO WRITE
ON YOUR HAND,
YOU PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
BE DOING THIS.
YOU'RE HERE TO SELL ME
SOMETHING, RIGHT?
>> THERE IS A NEW NATURAL
FACE MASK.
>> LIKE HALLOWEEN?
>> NO, NO, NO. HEY.
LET ME FINISH. ANTM.
>> A-N-T-M? ANTONYM?
>> YES.
>> NO.
>> ANTONYM HALLOWEEN MASK.
>> NO, IT'S ANTM.
>> GET IT AT YOUR LOCAL STORE.
>> NO, NO, YOU HAVE TO LISTEN.
YOU'RE GIVING ME
TOO HARD OF A TIME.
>> I'M SORRY. NIK, SHE ALMOST
GOT A CHANCE TO SELL
HER PRODUCT, BUT I REALLY
TOOK HER THE OTHER WAY.
>> OH, IT WAS A PLEASURE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THE BANANAS COME STRAIGHT--
>> BANANAS AND HONEY?
>> YEAH. THE BANANAS COME FROM,
LIKE, THE HILLS OF CARACAS.
>> WHERE'S THAT?
>> I DON'T EXACTLY KNOW,
BUT I'VE HEARD THEY HAVE
REALLY GOOD BANANAS.
>> THEY'RE KNOWN FOR
THEIR BANANAS, HUH?
>> YEAH.
>> CAN I TELL YOU
ABOUT MY PRODUCT?
I CREATED IT MYSELF FROM HOURS
OF SLAVING AWAY IN THE KITCHEN.
YOU DO NOT WANT BLEMISHES
AND YOU DO NOT WANT BREAKOUTS,
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS WILL
PREVENT.
>> WE WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
YOUR REAL LIFE.
MY REAL LIFE? MY REAL LIFE
IS ABOUT THE PRODUCT,
BECAUSE I MADE THIS PRODUCT.
>> YOU MADE IT?
>> IN THE BANANA, THERE IS
FOLIC ACID AND VITAMIN C.
IT'S A FIRMING MASK.
>> FIRMING?
SO IT MAKES YOU FEEL TIGHT.
>> YES, BUT YOU CAN PUT SOME
ON YOUR BUNS AND YOUR BREASTS,
AND THAT'S A LITTLE--
>> YOU HAVE SOME ON YOUR BREAST
RIGHT NOW?
>> OF COURSE.
>> LISA, SHE'S TOO COCKY.
SHE THINKS SHE IS GOING TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
>> ALL OF THE PRODUCTS BASICALLY
COME FROM
INGREDIENTS THAT YOU CAN FIND
IN YOUR KITCHEN.
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> LIKE BANANAS AND HONEY
AND CUCUMBERS AND TOMATOES
AND OATMEAL AND ALL THAT STUFF.
>> THIS PRODUCT HAS
TOMATO IN IT?
>> YEAH.
>> IT HAS BANANA, HONEY
AND TOMATO.
>> NO, IT'S JUST TOMATO.
>> LISA HAS NO CLUE.
I GUESS LISA COMPLETELY
MISSED THE MEMO.
>> WE HAVE CLEANSERS AND CREAMS
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
>> WHAT'S ALL THIS?
THIS SOME NEW DANCE?
>> YEAH. I'M GROOVING.
>> I WANT YOU TO DANCE WHILE
YOU DO THE WHOLE INTERVIEW.
>> UHH.
OHH.
>> BABY, WE RAN OUT OF TIME.
>> NO.
>> YES.
IN TERMS OF HITTING THE
PRODUCT POINT,
SOME OF YOU KIND OF GOT THERE,
AND THEN I SAID SOMETHING
AS YOU JUST TOOK OFF THAT WAY.
I ONLY GET TO CHOOSE ONE WINNER,
AND I GO WITH KYLE.
>> COOL. HEY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHAT YOU'VE WON IS
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> OH, COOL.
>> AND THAT SPECIAL THING ALLOWS
YOU TO BRING ONE OF THESE YOUNG
LADIES TO PARTICIPATE WITH YOU.
>> OKAY, I'M GONNA MIX IT UP.
I'M GONNA GO WITH NICOLE.
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED,
'CAUSE I HAVEN'T BEEN PICKED
TO DO ANYTHING YET.
>> VH1 HAS A NEW SHOW CALLED
"THE FABULOUS LIFE OF
SUPER MODELS."
AND YOU AND NICOLE GET
TO HOST THE SHOW.
YOU GET TO COUNTDOWN THE
TOP FIVE MOST FABULOUS
SUPERMODELS ON THE PLANET.
>> KYLE, OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD!
SHUT UP!
>> VH1 IS HOT.
>> YOU CAN'T WIN TWO IN A ROW.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
>> LISA'S WAS THE BEST.
>> THEY WERE ALL LAUGHING AT ME,
LIKE I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU GOT UP
AND YOU STARTED DANCING.
AND THEN CORYN SAID "YOU NEED TO
COME UP WITH ANOTHER DANCE MOVE"
IS WHAT YOU SAID.
>> EXACTLY.
>> THAT WAS MY LIMIT.
I COULDN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
YOU NEED TO STOP HATING
ON PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY ME.
>> WHAT? ARE YOU SERIOUS?
OH, MY GOODNESS.
OKAY, I'M DONE WITH YOU.
FORGET IT. FORGET IT.
>> OKAY. OKAY.
>> YOU DON'T HATE ON ME,
BUT YET YOU GO AROUND
TO THESE GIRLS AND TELL THEM
THAT THEY NEED TO WORK ON THIS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK THAT I'M BEING A FRIEND
INSTEAD OF BLOWING SMOKE
UP EVERYBODY'S ASS.
>> YOU'RE NOT BEING A FRIEND.
YOU AIN'T NO FRIEND TO NOBODY.
>> YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE
THAT SERIOUSLY DISLIKES ME.
>> I'M THE ONLY ONE
THAT TOLD YOU TO YOUR FACE
THAT I DO NOT LIKE YOU.
>> OKAY, THAT'S REALLY SAD.
I'M NOT TRYING TO HURT ANYBODY.
I'M REALLY JUST TRYING
TO HELP EVERYONE, HONESTLY.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> DON'T GO OVER THERE
AND TALK ABOUT IT.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING,
TALK ABOUT IT TO ME.
>> WILL YOU SHUT UP?
WHY ARE YOU STILL TALKING TO ME?
SHUT UP! I DO NOT LIKE YOU.
I TOLD YOU THAT A LONG TIME AGO.
>> THEN DON'T TALK ABOUT ME.
DON'T TALK TO ME.
DON'T MAKE SNAPPY COMMENTS
TO ME.
JUST PRETEND I DON'T EXIST.
>> JUST SHUT UP AND I CAN
PRETEND LIKE YOU DON'T EXIST.
>> THAT IS SO RUDE.
GROW UP, CORYN.
YOU'RE BASICALLY PRESENTING
YOURSELF LIKE A MORON, OKAY?
>> AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
ALCOHOLIC BITCH?
♪♪♪
>> WHY ARE YOU STILL
TALKING TO ME?
>> YOU'RE BASICALLY PRESENTING
YOURSELF LIKE A MORON, OKAY?
>> AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
ALCOHOLIC BITCH?
>> AT THIS POINT, I REALIZED
THAT I'M NOT AROUND PEOPLE WHO
LOVE AND CARE FOR ME, AND IT
HURTS BECAUSE I'VE NEVER REALLY
TRUTHLY BEEN HATED BY ANYBODY
BEFORE.
>> IT HURTS ME WHEN PEOPLE
ARE HARD ON OTHER PEOPLE.
LIKE, THAT BOTHERS ME.
FOR SOME REASON, I'M JUST
SENSITIVE TO THOSE SITUATIONS.
THERE'S TOO MUCH DRAMA
GOING ON RIGHT NOW,
AND I CAN'T DEAL WITH IT.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
I KINDA PULL BACK A LITTLE BIT,
BECAUSE EVEN YOUR FRIENDS
CAN HURT YOU.
I'VE SEEN TOO MANY THINGS
TO TRY TO, LIKE,
REACH OUT TO SOMEBODY NOW.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO SAY ABOUT LISA.
SHE THINKS SHE KNOWS IT ALL,
WHICH IS A PROBLEM.
SHE REALLY HAS TO GET OVER THAT.
>> THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE
SITTING AROUND SAYING LIKE
THERE'S NOT MUCH DRAMA SO FAR,
LIKE IT'S ALL FINE AND DANDY.
>> IT IS SO LIKE
HIGH SCHOOL HERE.
>> I WON THE CHANCE TO HOST
THE VH1 TOP FIVE MODEL
COUNTDOWN OF THE YEAR, AND I
PICKED NICOLE TO COME WITH ME.
>> I'M KEVIN FROM
"THE FABULOUS LIFE."
>> I'M NICOLE. IT'S NICE
TO MEET YOU.
>> HAVE YOU GUYS SEEN
THE SHOW "THE FABULOUS LIFE"?
SO YOU KNOW IT'S PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT SORT OF LIFESTYLES AND
MONEY.
WE'RE GONNA BE COUNTING DOWN
THE TOP FIVE SUPERMODELS.
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT THE WHOLE
SCRIPT A COUPLE OF TIMES.
A LOT OF ENERGY, BE YOURSELVES.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT.
ACTION!
>> NUMBER FIVE IS GERMAN STUNNER
HEIDI KLUM.
FROM VICTORIA SECRET ANGEL
TO "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
SWIM SUIT COVER,
IT'S NO WONDER THEY CALL HER
"THE BODY."
>> LISA EXPECTS TO WIN
EVERY SINGLE COMPETITION,
AS WE ALL DO.
I JUST THINK SHE TAKES IT
A LITTLE HARDER WHEN SHE DOESN'T
WIN THE COMPETITION.
>> IF I DID THE VH1 THING,
I WOULD HAVE DEFINITELY DONE
BETTER.
I WISH I WON THAT CHALLENGE.
I WOULD TALK VERY SOPHISTICATED
AND GIVE THEM MY HONEST
OPINIONS.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO GET
ROOM TONE IN THE OTHER ROOM.
>> I'M PRACTICING IN CASE I WON.
>> I UNDERSTAND, UM,
BUT WE JUST NEED YOU TO BE QUIET
FOR, LIKE, 30 SECONDS.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR PRACTICING.
IF YOU COULD HOLD IT
FOR 30 SECONDS...
>> HOLD IT FOR 30...
>> JUST HOLD IT 30 SECONDS.
I KNOW IT'S HARD.
BE QUIET FOR 30 SECONDS.
OKAY, READY.
WE'RE GONNA DO ROOM TONE.
>> HE JUST DOESN'T EVEN KNOW.
HE JUST DOESN'T EVEN GET IT.
>> ACTION.
>> EVER SINCE HER DISCOVERY
AT THE TENDER AGE OF 14,
KATE HAS BEEN THE FACE
OF PROVOCATIVE FASHION.
>> CUT. THAT'S GOOD.
YOU GUYS STEPPED IN LIKE PROS.
IT WAS AMAZING, SO...
REALLY NICE JOB.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK
THAT LISA'S DRINKING
IS HURTING HER.
THE JUDGES ARE NOT GONNA
WANT SOMEONE WHO'S AN ALCOHOLIC
TO REPRESENT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> HER ATTITUDE AND LIKE HER
DRINKING
AND EVERYTHING SHE'S DOING HERE
IS JUST BIZARRE TO ME.
>> (belch)
>> IT'S HARD TO BE AROUND HER
ALL THE TIME.
>> YOU MIGHT AS WELL JUST--
>> LISA.
>> SHE'S DRUNK.
>> I KNOW THAT SHE'S DRUNK.
>> I AM IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
IN THE HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
I'M PERCEIVED DIFFERENTLY.
NO ONE'S LOOKING AT
THE GOOD THINGS I'VE DONE
OR THE NICE THINGS I'VE DONE.
NO ONE'S CUTTING ME ANY SLACK.
I FEEL BETRAYED BY ALL OF THEM.
I HAVE BEEN HURT.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO TRUST.
I LOVE COUSIN "IT."
I FEEL LIKE ME AND COUSIN "IT"
ARE ALMOST THE SAME.
WHAT'S THE SECRET?
NO, IT'S COOL, MAN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TELL ME.
>> HER DRINKING IS
BECOMING A LOT HEAVIER
AND SHE'S BECOMING A LOT
MORE DEPENDENT ON IT.
SHE NEEDS SOMETHING,
A CRUTCH TO HOLD HER UP
FROM EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH EVERY DAY.
>> IT'S JUST HARD TO
KEEP IT TOGETHER.
IT'S JUST HARD
TO KEEP IT TOGETHER.
>> IT'S OKAY, HONEY.
>> A LOT OF TIMES I THINK
I'M TOO JUST SENSITIVE
FOR STUFF LIKE THIS.
>> LISA IS VERY CONFIDENT,
BUT AS MUCH CONFIDENCE
AS SHE HAS, SHE'S JUST TAKING IN
EVERY PUNCH AND EVERY BALL
THAT'S THROWN HER WAY,
ALL THE ARGUMENTS,
ALL THE CRITICIZING,
SHE'S EATING IT,
AND IT'S EATING AWAY AT HER NOW.
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
>> I KNOW FOR A FACT NONE OF US
HAVE EVER BEEN UNDER
SO MUCH STRESS AND ANXIETY
AS WE ARE HERE.
>> IT'S LIKE IT'S
JUST EXPLODING.
>> LISTEN, HOLD YOUR BREATH
FOR, LIKE, TEN SECONDS, REALLY.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND HOLD IT.
>> REALLY, COME ON.
YOU'RE BREATHING ALL CRAZY.
JUST TAKE A DEEP BREATH
AND HOLD IT.
>> NOBODY REALLY KNOWS
HOW TO HELP HER, THOUGH.
NOBODY.
LISA, YOU NEED TO FOCUS.
COME ON NOW.
PULL IT TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
>> HELLO! HI.
COME ON OUT HERE, GUYS.
GRAB SOME PILLOWS.
YOU SOUND REALLY SLEEPY.
>> SO WE GO UPSTAIRS AND TYRA IS
STANDING RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
I STILL HAVE CURLERS IN MY HAIR.
>> NO, NO, THAT'S FINE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
NOT TRYING TO IMPRESS ME.
WHAT ABOUT VICES?
ARE YOU GUYS DEALING WITH
ANY, LIKE, VICES OR ANYTHING?
>> SLEEP.
>> WHAT DOES SLEEP DO FOR YOU?
>> RESTORES YOU MENTALLY TO
GET PREPARED FOR OUR NEXT PHOTO
SHOOT, FOR OUR NEXT CRITICISM.
>> WHO SMOKES?
>> IT'S NOT ILLEGAL.
98% OF MODELS SMOKE
OR HAVE SMOKED.
AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT THEY DO
TO KEEP THEIR WEIGHT OFF.
AND GRANDMOM DIED OF LUNG CANCER
AT 50.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO JUST
GET SUPERFICIAL AND TALK ABOUT
MODELING, THIS...
CAREER WILL BE CUT IN HALF
BECAUSE OF SMOKING.
AND IT'S NOT TOO EASY TO QUIT,
BECAUSE MY ADDICTION IS FOOD
AND FATTENING FOOD.
SO IF SOMEBODY'S, LIKE,
A MODEL'S LIFE WILL BE
CUT IN HALF, TYRA, BY EATING,
I AIN'T GONNA PUT DOWN THE
TWINKIE. YOU KNOW WAHT I MEAN.
NOT THAT EASILY.
ANY OTHER VICES?
>> I DRINK WINE.
>> YOU'RE A WINO?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU ARE? I THOUGHT
YOU WERE GONNA SAY NO.
>> YEAH, I'M A WINO.
>> YOU HAVE A DRINK EVERY DAY?
>> UM, NO, I DON'T HAVE TO.
WHEN I HAVE A GLASS OF WINE,
IT'S JUST LIKE, I DON'T KNOW,
THE FEELING THAT IT DOES FOR ME
IS REALLY NICE, IT'S RELAXING.
>> DO YOU DRINK TO GET DRUNK?
>> MNH-MNH.
>> LISA SAID, NO, SHE DOESN'T.
AND IT KINDA MADE ME MAD
THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
LYING TO TYRA RIGHT TO HER FACE.
>> SO I'LL BE SEEING
YOU GUYS LATER.
ALL RIGHT?
>> THANK YOU.
>> BYE.
>> TYRA MAIL.
HOW WELL CAN YOU JUGGLE?
FIND OUT TOMORROW.
BE READY AT 8:00 A.M.
TYRA.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER,
BUT THIS COMPETITION
MEANS A LOT TO ME.
I'M THROWING IN ALL MY CHIPS,
AND HOPEFULLY IT WILL WORK OUT
IN THE END.
>> GOOD MORNING. HOW ARE YA?
TODAY WE'RE DOING A SHOOT
FOR SECRET PLATINUM CLEAR GEL.
YOU'RE GONNA WORK
THE KIND OF HECTIC DAY
A REAL SUPERMODEL WORKS
WITH A TV COMMERCIAL,
PHOTO SHOOT AND PRESS INTERVIEW
WITH "ET's" RYAN DEVLIN
ALL IN ONE DAY.
SO I WANNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO BILL HEUBERGER.
HE IS GONNA BE YOUR
COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR.
AND JASON WILLHEIM,
WHO IS GOING TO BE DOING
YOUR STILL SHOOT TODAY.
>> HEY, GIRLS.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY?
>> AND JUST SO YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
PUT YOUR OWN TWIST
ON THE COMMERCIAL BY REVEALING
YOUR OWN PERSONAL SECRETS.
LET'S GO TO WORK.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT-LIGHT.
>> ACTION.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU DON'T HOLD ANYTHING BACK.
YOU'RE BRAVER, GUTSIER
AND YOU'RE MORE SECURE.
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG, YOU MAY REVEAL
SOMETHING ABOUT YOURSELF THAT
YOU ORDINARILY WOULDN'T.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I TELL MYSELF I'M BEAUTIFUL
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> IT'S RELATABLE.
THAT LITTLE BIT OF
VULNERABILITY IS GREAT.
>> ♪ AH ♪
>> LISA'S SHOOT WENT
REALLY WELL,
WHICH EVERYONE REALLY
WASN'T EXPECTING.
WE THOUGHT THAT, YOU KNOW, LISA
WAS GONNA BE A LITTLE
OFF OF HER GAME.
>> I DO FEEL POSITIVE ABOUT
THE COMMERCIAL.
I DEFINITELY NAILED IT PERFECTLY
AND I'M PROUD OF MYSELF
FOR THAT.
AS I GO INTO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I CAN'T STOP SMILING.
>> GOOD.
>> NOW WE GO STRAIGHT
INTO AN INTERVIEW
WHERE WE ARE THE SPOKESPERSON
FOR SECRET PLATINUM.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING, LISA?
>> THEY GOT A REALLY HOT GUY
TO INTERVIEW US.
OH, LIKE THAT'S GONNA
DISTRACT ME.
LET'S DO THIS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU,
BUT, LIKE, I'M ITALIAN,
AND WE'RE JUST KNOWN
TO BE SWEATY PEOPLE.
>> OKAY.
>> SERIOUSLY, SECRET PLATINUM--
IT WORKS.
IT SERIOUSLY WORKS.
>> ALL LIES.
>> SEE, IT'S GOOD UNDER THERE.
IT'S NICE, RIGHT?
>> THE FIRST THING THAT WE DO
IS WE GO AND DO A COMMERCIAL.
AND WE HAVE 10 MINUTES
TO GET GET IT DONE
AND GET IT PERFECT.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I EAT ICE CREAM IN BED.
>> YOU'RE BRAVER, GUTSIER
AND MORE SECURE.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU'RE BRAVER--
>> NOT TOO MUCH.
DON'T GET TOO OVER THE TOP.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG.
WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG.
>> THAT'S IT.
OH, GOD.
>> FROM THERE WE GO OVER
AND DO PHOTO SHOOT.
TEN MINUTES OF THAT, TOO,
TO NAIL YOUR SHOT.
>> MORE BEING ELEGANT
AND LONG NECKED.
YOU GOT IT NOW. NICE.
KEEP CHANGING.
>> AND FROM THERE YOU GO
AND MEET WITH RYAN
FROM "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
>> YOU HAVE BEAUTIFUL EYES.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
THAT'S VERY SWEET OF YOU TO SAY.
YOU AS WELL.
>> I THINK I'VE GOT A
CRUSH ON YOU.
>> OH, WOW.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
ONE THING THAT YOU'VE DONE
THAT YOU ARE GONNA BE
REALLY EMBARRASSED TO SEE?
>> THERE IS JUST A WHOLE
LIST TO CHOOSE FROM,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> WHAT'S YOUR SECRET?
>> I EAT ICE CREAM IN BED.
>> THAT'S KIND OF G-RATED.
>> YEAH.
>> AND I WASN'T EVEN
FISHING FOR THAT.
>> ONE THING, ANOTHER THING
ANOTHER THING--JUST GET IT DONE,
GET IT DONE, GET IT DONE.
>> CORYN--TAKE ONE.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG--
>> WE'RE GONNA STOP YOU.
PULL IT BACK OUT.
REAL QUICK, AND STAND BY.
>> AS SOON AS I START OFF BAD,
I BEAT MYSELF UP ABOUT IT.
AND FROM THERE ON,
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
I COULDN'T DO IT.
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT AND...
STRONG.
>> WHO ARE YOU TOTALLY
COMFORTABLE WITH?
>> THERE'S NOBODY.
>> NOBODY. NOT EVEN ME?
>> THERE'S REALLY NOBODY.
>> DAMN.
NOW YOU SEE, THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO SEE, THAT LAUGH,
THAT GIGGLE, THIS BRIGHT.
LET'S GO. LET'S ROLL ON IT.
>> OKAY, START IT.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU DON'T HOLD ANYTHING BACK.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M AFRAID OF HEIGHTS.
>> PRAISE THE LORD, JESUS!
I BELIEVE THE LAST ONE.
YOU ARE SO LUCKY.
>> GIRL!
>> LONGER NECK.
LOOKS REALLY GOOD.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY?
>> NOTHING.
JUST DOING A COMMERCIAL
FOR THE NEW PLATINUM.
>> PLATINUM BLING?
PLATINUM JEWELRY?
>> NO, PLATINUM DEODORANT.
>> PLATINUM DEODORANT?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION?
>> THE SAME SECRET?
>> MINE'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
SHE'S AFRAID OF THE DARK
BUT I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT-LIGHT.
NOW I'M WORRIED ABOUT
HOW I'M GOING TO PERFORM.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE SAME LINE.
AND I THINK JAYLA STOLE
MY SECRET.
>> THAT'S REALLY YOUR
LITTLE SECRET?
THEN WORK IT.
>> JAYLA--TAKE ONE.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M SCARED OF THE DARK.
>> LOOSE UP A BIT MORE. JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE PERSONALITY FROM
YOU.
AGAIN. STAND BY, AND NOW.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL CONFIDENT
AND STRONG,
YOU MIGHT REVEAL SOMETHING
ABOUT YOURSELF THAT ORDINARILY
YOU WOULD NOT.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT-LIGHT.
>> WASN'T HERS JUST
I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK?
>> YEAH.
>> JUST CHECKING.
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED.
>> IT WAS KIND OF SHOCKING TO ME
THAT JAYLA WOULD TAKE HER LINE
'CAUSE THAT'S JUST WRONG.
>> GREAT.
REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
YOU'RE MAKING THIS SO EASY.
>> MY BODY LOOKED REALLY GOOD.
OOH! THAT WAS PAINFUL.
I'M GONNA HAVE A GOOD PHOTO
TO PULL OUT OF THIS ONE.
>> GOING IN, WE BOTH KNOW
THEY'RE FAIRLY SIMILAR.
>> AND SHE GOES FIRST,
AND SHE DOES THAT.
>> YEAH.
I JUST THINK THAT'S SO UGLY.
>> HOW IS IT GOING?
>> GOOD.
>> WHAT ABOUT ME IS AMAZING?
>> LET'S SEE, WHEN I WALKED IN,
YOU LOOKED EXACTLY LIKE
ONE OF MY COUSINS.
>> JAYLA WAS FANTASTIC.
SHE WAS SUPER CUTE, YOU KNOW?
SHE CAME IN AND SHE WAS
BUBBLY AND CONFIDENT.
ENJOY THE REST YOUR DAY.
>> THANK YOU. YOU, TOO.
>> I WILL.
> I WANT WHAT EVERYONE WANTS
OUT OF THIS COMPETITION,
AND THAT'S TO WIN.
AS FAR AS FRIENDSHIPS GO,
GREAT IF YOU HAVE 'EM,
IF YOU DON'T, OH, WELL.
>> AT THIS POINT,
I'M JUST TOO NERVOUS
TO CHANGE MY SECRET.
I'M GONNA STAY WITH IT
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
I PRACTICED IT.
IT'S SCARY, AND MY STOMACH
IS SERIOUSLY TURNING.
AND THIS IS WHY I DON'T WANT
TO GET CLOSE TO
A LOT OF THE GIRLS,
BECAUSE THEY HURT YOU.
>> WE'RE GONNA COME RIGHT IN
REALLY TIGHT ON YOU,
SO WHENEVER YOU TELL
US YOUR SECRET,
WHATEVER IT IS...
>> YEAH, I BET YOU HEARD
MY SECRET BEFORE.
>> NIK--TAKE ONE.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
>> KEEP LOOKING AT THE CAMERA.
DON'T LOOK AT US.
>> SORRY.
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG, YOU...
YOU DON'T HOLD--
>> HOLD ON. SORRY.
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER THE WORDS
THAT I ALREADY REMEMBERED
JUST BECAUSE MY NERVES HAVE
TAKEN CONTROL OVER ME.
THAT WAS STILL BAD?
>> THAT WASN'T BAD. JUST RELAX.
I'M JUST SAYIN' RELAX.
>> WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG,
YOU MIGHT...
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S IT.
I THINK YOU'RE JUST JUDGING
YOURSELF TOO MUCH.
JUST LAUGH ABOUT IT. OKAY.
>> IT'S OKAY
'CAUSE KARMA IS A BITCH.
>> BECAUSE WHAT?
>> BECAUSE KARMA'S A BITCH.
I THINK I'M TAKING ALL
OF THE NERVES
FROM THE COMMERCIAL
INTO THE PHOTO SHOOT.
>> YOU'VE DONE THIS BEFORE,
SO IT WILL BE EASY.
A PIECE OF CAKE.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT GOOD AT SMILEY
PHOTO SHOOTS.
>> BE MORE ELEGANT.
>> ALWAYS GIVE VARIETY.
>> I WANT A LITTLE MORE
LONGER NECK.
>> I WAS LITERALLY SHAKING
ON THE FLOOR.
I JUST COULDN'T FEEL POSITIVE
AND CONFIDENT ABOUT MYSELF.
>> COLLAPSED?
>> YEAH.
I'VE BEEN SUCKING ALL DAY.
>> I'M RYAN.
>> HI, I'M RY--
HI, RYAN, I'M NIK.
HOPEFULLY I CAN GET
MY MIND TOGETHER
SO I CAN FOCUS MORE.
I REALLY THINK IF I DON'T
DO SO GREAT
THAT I COULD BE GOING HOME.
>> NOW WHAT WOULD BE THEN
THE ONE THING THAT YOU'RE
THE LEAST PROUD OF?
>> THE LEAST PROUD OF? HMM.
GOD, WHAT AM I LEAST PROUD OF?
HMM.
>> NIK COULDN'T THINK OF
A LEAST PROUD MOMENT.
YOU JUST GOTTA HAVE ONE READY
OR YOU GOTTA THINK ON YOUR TOES.
MAKE ONE UP. I DON'T KNOW.
>> OKAY. EXCUSE ME.
THIS WEEK IN PANEL,
I AM REALLY UNSURE
OF HOW I'M GOING TO DO.
I DON'T FEEL SO CONFIDENT
ABOUT MY SECURITY
IN THIS HOUSE ANYMORE.
>> I HAVE NOT SAID ANYTHING
TO JAYLA JUST 'CAUSE
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER IN KARMA.
IF SHE DID DO IT INTENTIONALLY,
WHATEVER'S GONNA HAPPEN
WILL COME BACK.
>> THE WHOLE THING WITH ME
AND NIK IS
I AM SICK OF HER GIVING ME
THE COLD SHOULDER.
>> AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHY THAT IS?
>> NO IDEA.
>> YOU HONESTLY DON'T
HAVE ANY IDEA?
>> ENLIGHTEN ME.
>> I CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT
'CAUSE I PROMISED I WOULDN'T.
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY, SO WHAT DID YOU GUYS
HAVE IN COMMON TODAY?
>> OH, OUR SECRETS?
>> AND WHAT DID YOU
END UP SAYING?
>> THAT I WAS SCARED OF THE
DARK.
>> THAT'S IT?
>> I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT-LIGHT.
SHE'S PISSED AT ME
BECAUSE I SAID THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S SO RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S SO RIDICULOUS.
I AM SICK OF BEING IN A HOUSE
WITH SOMEONE THAT'S JUST
SO STUPID LIKE THAT.
IT'S JUST SO STUPID.
IT'S JUST STUFF LIKE,
IT MAKES ME REALIZE
HOW FEW PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE
I'M GONNA BE FRIENDS WITH
WHEN THIS IS ALL DONE.
THERE'S PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE
THAT I TOLERATE ONLY BECAUSE
I HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO TOLERATE THEM,
AND THAT'S ALL I DO.
>> YOU KNOW I CAN HEAR YOU,
RIGHT?
>> SHE'S CUT OFF.
SHE IS OFFICIALLY ON
MY BAD SIDE.
AND I PREDICT THAT IN THE
FUTURE,
IF WE ARE TOGETHER LONG ENOUGH,
SOMETHING BIG'S GONNA HAPPEN.
SOMETHING BIG IS GONNA GO DOWN.
MARK MY WORDS. IT'LL HAPPEN.
♪♪♪
>> YOU GUYS, WE HAVE TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES."
>> "ONLY SEVEN OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> "ONE WILL BE ELIMINATED."
>> I'M VERY NERVOUS.
VERY, VERY, VERY NERVOUS
'CAUSE I KNOW
I DIDN'T DO THAT GOOD WITH
THE COMMERCIAL.
I KNOW I CAN DO A LOT BETTER.
>> AT THIS POINT,
IF I GET ELIMINATED,
I'D PROBABLY BE REALLY CRUSHED.
I CAN'T GO HOME.
>> THERE'S ONE PERSON
IN THIS HOUSE
THAT I SEVERELY,
SEVERELY DISLIKE,
ON THE BORDERLINE OF HATE.
THAT'S NIK.
THE ONE THING THAT I REALLY,
REALLY HOPE HAPPENS RIGHT NOW
IS THAT SHE KEEPS THE SAME
STUPID FACIAL EXPRESSION
IN ALL HER PICTURES
AND KEEPS ON WITH HER LITTLE,
"I'M A NICE GIRL, AND I HAVE
NO PERSONALITY" ATTITUDE AT
PANEL.
THAT WAY THEY'RE LIKE, "HMM,
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT, YOU SUCK.
BYE-BYE."
>> NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR FIFTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRINGS US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS, A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A COVER OF
"ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER.
OUR FABULOUS RUNWAY COACH
AND DIVA, MISS J. ALEXANDER.
TWIGGY, A LEGENDARY ICON
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
AND MR. BILL HEUBERGER, WHO WAS
YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR,
AND HE'S ALSO A PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT I'VE SHOT WITH.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT, THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE AND WE'LL
DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
NOW THIS WEEK YOU GUYS DID
A PHOTO SHOOT, YOU HAD TO DO
A COMMERCIAL AND THEN
YOU HAD TO DO INTERVIEWS
ABOUT WHAT YOU WERE SELLING.
THE REASON WHY I
CAME UP WITH THAT IDEA
IS BECAUSE WHEN I DO
VICTORIA'S SECRET,
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET THE MOST
BANG FOR THEIR BUCK.
SO THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO
INTERVIEWS ONE DAY
AND PHOTO SHOOTS ONE DAY
AND A COMMERCIAL ONE DAY.
THEY DO IT ALL IN ONE DAY.
BUT IT'S WHAT THE CLIENT WANTS,
IT SAVES MONEY, AND IT WORKS.
NICOLE, YOU'RE FIRST.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH YOUR
COMMERCIAL
FOR... (sniffs) DEODORANT.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL CONFIDENT
AND STRONG,
YOU MIGHT REVEAL SOMETHING
THAT OTHERWISE YOU MIGHT NOT.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I EAT ICE CREAM IN BED.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOUR
SPEAKING VOICE IS REALLY NICE.
WHAT I SEE HERE IS A LITTLE
DIAMOND IN THE ROUGH.
>> YOU ALSO HAD A PUBLICITY
INTERVIEW
WITH "E.T.'s" RYAN DEVLIN.
>> WHY HAVEN'T YOU TOLD ME
ABOUT THIS DEODORANT?
>> WELL, I JUST FOUND
THIS NEW DEODORANT.
IT'S THE SECRET, UM...
PLATINUM.
UM, THEY HAVE, LIKE,
FOUR DIFFERENT SCENTS OF IT.
IT SMELLS REALLY AMAZING.
>> WITH THE PRODUCT,
LET'S KEEP IT REAL.
I MEAN, ALL OF THOSE "UMS,"
AND IT KINDA MAKES ME SMELL
GOOD, AND, UM...
IF YOU ARE AN ENDORSER,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS,
YOU KNOW IT,
YOU USE IT ALL OF THE TIME.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
"YOU PROBABLY COULD USE SOME."
YOU KNOW, JUST HAVE FUN
WITH THE INTERVIEWER.
YOU DID A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR SECRET AS WELL.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I THINK THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> THE CAMERA LOVES YOU.
>> I JUST WANT TO LET
EVERYBODY KNOW THAT
YOU GUYS ALL SHOT A SECRET AD.
ONE OF THEM WILL ACTUALLY RUN
IN THIS WEEK'S ISSUE
OF "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE.
AND IT'LL BE THE GIRL
WHO THE JUDGES DECIDE
HAS THE STRONGEST PICTURE TODAY.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS JAYLA.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M SCARED OF THE DARK
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT-LIGHT.
>> THERE'S THAT MODEL THING
THAT YOU DID.
I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK,
AND I'M CUTE.
DON'T YOU WANT ME?
>> WHAT I LIKE ABOUT SECRET
IS I LOVE THE WAY IT SMELLS.
I MEAN, IT'S
THE FIRST DEODORANT
THAT I'VE USED THAT I PUT IT ON
AND I ACTUALLY DON'T SWEAT.
I MEAN, A LOT OF DEODORANTS
CLAIM THAT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
SECRET ACTUALLY DOES IT.
>> YOU GOT THE BRAND NAME IN
QUITE A FEW TIMES,
WHICH IS REALLY GOOD.
>> HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT
FROM THE PHOTO SHOOT.
I LIKE THE LIPS.
>> I LOVE THE LITTLE LIPS
AND I DO LOVE THE EYES.
>> THIS ISN'T REALLY CONNECTING
FOR ME.
THERE'S SOMETHING OFF
IN THE FACIAL EXPRESSION.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN YOU ENOUGH.
I DON'T FEEL ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
>> UP NEXT IS CORYN.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M AFRAID OF HEIGHTS.
>> THERE IS A SADNESS IN YOU
THAT I FEEL A LITTLE BIT THAT
YOU HAVE TO FIGHT THROUGH.
>> PERSONALLY, I HAVE
THE PEACH KIND
AND IT SMELLS GOOD ALL DAY LONG
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO REAPPLY IT
AND STUFF EVERY DAY.
>> HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
AN INTERVIEW
WITH A FAMOUS PERSON
OR A STAR OR A CELEBRITY
THAT WAS THAT SORT OF
MELANCHOLY?
NO.
>> SO UP NEXT, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT FOR SECRET.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU'VE ACTUALLY GOT
PERSONALITY AND SENSE OF HUMOR
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
>> YOU DID LOOK SAD IN YOUR
FILM,
BUT YOU NAILED IT WITH THIS.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT WE HAVE
KYLE.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU'RE BRAVER, GUTSIER
AND MORE SECURE.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I LOVE TO SING AND DANCE
IN FRONT OF THE MIRROR.
>> SING-SONGY.
IT WAS VERY UP AND UP AND UP.
WHICH IS NOT THE NICEST
THING LISTEN TO.
>> IN A REAL ENVIRONMENT,
WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE PULLED IT BACK.
YOU ARE GUILTY OF OVERACTING.
>> TELL ME WHAT DO YOU LIKE
ABOUT SECRET DEODORANT?
>> I LIKE THE SMELL.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE THING
IS THE SMELL,
AND, OF COURSE,
I LIKE THE FACT THAT
IT PREVENTS ME FROM SWEATING...
>> RIGHT.
>> AND PREVENTS ME
FROM SMELLING.
>> IMPORTANT.
>> I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU
WERE HAVING A DIALOGUE WITH
THE PERSON INTERVIEWING YOU.
YOU WERE LIKE,
"YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?"
LIKE, "YEAH, I KNOW, AND WHEN
I DO THIS IT'S REALLY GOOD."
AS OPPOSED TO JUST BEING
A COMPUTER THAT'S GIVING OUT
THE FACTS.
>> IT'S PRETTY BUT NOT POWERFUL.
>> COULD HAVE BEEN STRONGER
FOR ME.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A
LOT STRONGER.
>> CALL ME OLD-FASHIONED,
BUT I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> ALL RIGHT. UP NEXT IS BRE.
>> WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I LOVE MEN'S UNDERWEAR.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS FANTASTIC.
>> I LOVE YOUR ENDING.
THAT ENDING WAS CUTE
BECAUSE YOU LOOKED DOWN
AND IT WAS REALLY REAL.
>> BOXERS OR BRIEFS?
>> BRIEFS, BABY.
I USE SECRET PLATINUM,
WHICH IS A DEODORANT,
AND IT'S PRETTY AWESOME
BECAUSE, UM, FIRST OF ALL,
IT GOES ON CLEAR,
SO USUALLY
WHEN I GO OUT AT NIGHT, I HAVE
ON LIKE BLACK SHIRTS
AND STUFF SO I DON'T GET,
LIKE, A LOT OF STAINS
FROM THE GEL ON IT.
>> RIGHT.
>> I THOUGHT YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE
REALLY, REALLY NATURAL.
>> YOU LOOK A BIT BORED.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE
A BAD SMELL UNDER YOUR NOSE,
SLIGHTLY.
>> I FEEL SHE'S GUARDED IN THAT.
>> KIM.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU DON'T HOLD ANYTHING BACK.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I WALK AND TALK TOUGH,
BUT I SCREAM LIKE A GIRL.
>> I JUST HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THE POSTURE.
>> YOU'RE AN ANOMALY TO ME, KIM.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
ABOUT YOU, BUT IT WORKS.
AND THAT'S A SPECIAL THING.
DON'T LOSE IT.
>> MY FRIEND'S LIKE, "OH,
YOU SHOULD TRY THIS SECRET
PLATINUM ANTIPERSPIRANT."
SO, YOU KNOW, I TRIED IT,
AND WAS INTO IT AND SO I WAS
WORKING WITH IT FOR AWHILE
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
A FEW DAYS AGO I GOT THIS CALL
AFTER AN AUDITION THAT I WENT
TO THAT I WAS ASKED TO BE
THE NEW POWDER FRESH
ANTIPERSPIRANT--
>> WAS IT BECAUSE SOMEONE
OVERHEARD THAT CONVERSATION?
>> IT'S REALLY WEIRD.
>> THERE'S ONE THING
THAT I LOVE THAT YOU DID,
YOU GAVE AN ANECDOTE.
LIKE, ANECDOTES ARE
THE BEST THING.
>> OH, THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> WE RETOUCHED YOUR ARM
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
KIM, IF YOU'RE, LIKE,
LAYING DOWN OR WHATEVER,
DON'T PUSH IT.
YOU HAVE THE SAME THING.
SO YOU HAVE TO, LIKE,
PUSH IT OUT.
>> LISA, WHAT WAS GOING ON
WHEN WE WERE
GETTING DRESSED TODAY?
>> I FELT SO PLAYFUL
THIS MORNING AND, LIKE,
I JUST WANTED TO JUST BE
LIKE A BUBBLE.
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T MIND IT.
I THINK IT'S SO WRONG,
IT'S RIGHT, AGAIN.
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT
GOING ON TODAY.
>> WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU DON'T HOLD ANYTHING BACK.
YOU'RE BRAVER, GUTSIER
AND YOU'RE MORE SECURE.
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG, YOU MAY
REVEAL SOMETHING ABOUT YOURSELF
THAT YOU ORDINARILY WOULDN'T.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I TELL MYSELF I'M BEAUTIFUL
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> I'M DOING THIS.
YOU BROUGHT TEARS TO MY EYES.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
WE HAVE SEEN.
>> I FELT SHE HAD THE BEST RAW,
NATURAL TALENT.
>> WHO'S MOST LIKELY
TO STAB YOU IN THE BACK?
>> AREN'T WE SUPPOSED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT DEODORANT
RIGHT NOW?
>> I--ARE WE?
>> THERE'S, LIKE, THIS
DEODORANT
THAT I JUST STARTED USING
AND IT'S AMAZING.
THIS ACTUALLY WORKS.
MAYBE YOU CAN USE IT, TOO.
>> THAT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> I LOVED IT.
>> YOU REALLY GOT HIM.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS ALMOST
IRRITATING THAT YOU
REFUSED TO ANSWER HIS QUESTION,
YOU LOOKED SO GORGEOUS.
I LOVE THE PICTURE.
>> I WOULD THINK THE CLIENT
WOULD LOVE THAT PHOTOGRAPH.
>> I THINK YOU'RE BRINGING
YOUR PERSONALITY
NOT JUST TO THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT TO THE INTERVIEW,
TO THE ACTUAL TV COMMERCIAL.
10 OUT OF 10, GOOD.
>> NIK.
NERVOUS?
>> YEAH.
WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG, YOU DON'T
LET ANYTHING HOLD YOU BACK.
YOU'RE BRAVER, GUTSIER
AND MORE SECURE.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK,
AND I SLEEP WITH A
NIGHT-LIGHT.
>> GIRL, YOUR SHOULDERS
WAS JUST UP HERE AND TIGHT.
>> I FELT UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> THE ONE THING I ALWAYS
TELL MYSELF I CAN'T DO
IS TALK INTO A CAMERA.
I HATE TO SAY THIS,
BECAUSE IT IS
DEFINITELY EMBARRASSING,
AND THIS IS ANOTHER
SECRET OF MINE.
I HAVE BAD B.O.
AND SO THE PLATINUM BRAND,
IT ACTUALLY KEEPS ME
PRETTY FRESH
AND SMELLING DAINTY,
LIKE A GIRL.
>> I LIKE THAT A PRETTY GIRL,
YOU KNOW, THAT JUST LOOKS
SO PERFECT IS LIKE,
"I GET FUNKY."
>> I THINK IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH
INFORMATION FOR ME.
>> BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
IT'S A SHAME THAT YOUR FOOT
IS GOING INTO YOUR HEAD.
>> SHE'S IMPALED BY A
SILVER SANDAL.
>> I'M GONNA TELL YOU
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA NOT LIKE TO HEAR,
BUT YOU HAD THE WEAKEST FILM.
>> NO EXCUSES, BUT IN THIS
RECENT PHOTO SHOOT,
I FELT HURT AND BETRAYED.
>> YOU MEAN, BETRAYED, LIKE,
BEHIND THE SCENES
OR LIKE SOMETHING WITH
OUR PERFORMANCE?
>> SOMETHING WENT ON,
BUT I THINK--
>> ELABORATE.
>> IT'S NOTHING.
>> NIK, YOU ARE A FORTRESS.
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE
OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
>> JAYLA?
>> I'M NOT COMPLETELY CONVINCED
ABOUT JAYLA.
HER EYES ARE NOT REALLY
WORKING FOR ME.
SHE'S A LITTLE CROSS-EYED
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
>> I THINK JAYLA'S FACE
IS MAGICAL,
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH ESPECIALLY.
IT'S JUST LIKE, BING.
YOU DON'T THINK SO,
BUT I THINK SO.
NIK.
>> THIS HAS NOT BEEN
A GOOD WEEK FOR NIK.
>> I DON'T SEE MODEL. I'M SORRY.
I DON'T SEE TOP MODEL.
>> SHE'S NOT PARTICULARLY
BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE'S SEXY.
>> NICOLE.
>> NICOLE LOOKS SENSATIONAL
IN THIS PICTURE.
>> A POTENTIAL DIAMOND
IN THE ROUGH.
>> I THINK SHE'S PRETTY,
BUT WHEN SHE STANDS BEFORE ME,
SHE'S A BIT JUST SORT OF
LIKE HERE NOR THERE.
>> KYLE.
>> SHE'S A LOVELY GIRL, BUT
SHE'S A BIT ORDINARY FOR ME.
>> KIM.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT KIM
THAT LEAVES
THE VIEWER WANTING MORE.
>> CORYN.
>> SHE REALLY LOOKS GREAT.
HER FACE LOOKS WONDERFUL.
>> SHE MAKES ME LIKE HER
BECAUSE SHE WAS SAD.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU BOOKED SOMEBODY, YOU KNOW...
>> FOR A HUMAN INTEREST STORY?
>> YEAH, I'M LIKE, I'M GONNA
BOOK THIS MODEL
BECAUSE I FEEL SORRY FOR HER.
THAT'S JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
>> BRE.
>> SHE LOOKS BORED.
>> YOU KNOW, THERE'S THE SAYING
AMONGST US FASHION FOLKS
THAT JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
CUTE IN PERSON
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GONNA
TRANSLATE INTO A PICTURE.
LISA.
>> I LOVE HOW SHE,
IN HER INTERVIEW,
TURNED THE ENTIRE QUESTION
AROUND TO THE PRODUCT.
SHE WILL NEVER BE THE GIRL
TO SAY, "NO COMMENT."
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS GIRL THAT
LEAVES YOU WANTING MORE.
HOWEVER, I ALSO CAN'T
STAND LISA.
>> EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SEVEN GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GONNA
CALL
IS SOMEONE WHO ROCKED IT.
YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE, MISS LISA.
GET ON UP HERE.
YOUR COMMERCIAL, YOUR INTERVIEW
AND THIS PHOTO ROCKED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS PHOTO'S
NOT GONNA BE THE AD.
AND MAJORITY RULED
ON ANOTHER GIRL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
JAYLA.
>> KIM.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL WILL BE THE AD
THAT WILL RUN IN A
MAGAZINE THIS WEEK.
>> NICOLE.
>> YOU'RE NOT EVEN AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND YOU GOT AN AD, GIRL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL IS YOU, KYLE.
YOU OVER THERE.
COME ON UP HERE AND GET YOUR
PICTURE.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
>> FOR WHAT?
>> FOR BEING SUCH A
HORRIBLE OVERACTOR.
SO DID YOU SEE HOW RIDICULOUS I
JUST SOUNDED AND LOOKED?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT WAS YOUR MIRROR.
SO YOU HAVE TO JUST
DESTROY THAT MIRROR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME I'M GOING TO
CALL...
BRE. CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL NIK AND CORYN PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
>> I'LL START WITH YOU, CORYN.
RIGHT NOW YOU STAND BEFORE ME--
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
YOU'RE SO RADIANT.
BUT YOU'RE SAD.
SOME OF THE JUDGES DISCUSSED
TONIGHT
THAT IN THE REAL WORLD OF
MODELING,
THEY WOULD NEVER HIRE A GIRL
THAT BROUGHT SUCH A SADNESS
TO THE SET.
SOME OF THEM SAID THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD SAVE YOU
FROM THIS CRAZY, CUTTHROAT
WORLD OF MODELING
THAT WOULD MAKE A SAD GIRL
EXTREMELY DEPRESSED.
NIK, THE REASON WHY
YOU'RE STANDING IN FRONT OF ME
IS BECAUSE YOU TOOK A PICTURE
THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE STRIPPED AND BEAUTIFUL,
AND YOU DIDN'T ROCK IT.
IN THE COMMERCIAL--
STIFF, VERY REHEARSED.
IN THE LONG RUN, WE'RE LOOKING
FOR SOMEBODY THAT IS
COMFORTABLE SPEAKING
INTO THE CAMERA.
YOU SAID THAT'S YOUR WEAKNESS.
>> NIK.
YOU HAVE TO WORK.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> IT'S JUST A LOAD OFF
MY SHOULDERS.
I FEEL LIKE I CAN BREATHE AGAIN.
IT'S JUST A LOT LESS STRESS
TO GO THROUGH.
IT'S MY TIME TO GO.
THERE'S OTHER THINGS OUT THERE
FOR ME.
MY LIFE IS GONNA CHANGE.
>> COMING UP ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,"
FITNESS IS THE WORD OF THE DAY,
BUT AFTER THIS OBSTACLE COURSE
NICOLE'S NAME MAY BE MUD...
>> STAY DOWN. YOU CAN'T
TOUCH THE NET.
>> I'M GONNA BARF.
THAT WAS SO NASTY.
>> NICE, GOOD.
EVEN MORE WITH THE LIPS.
>> AND A SEXY PHOTO SHOOT
PUTS KIM IN TOUCH WITH HER
FEMININE SIDE.
>> AND NOW IT'S STARTING
TO GET A LITTLE BUTCH.
♪♪♪